si Raúl Ayer fue una noche nuevamente de
protestas poco a poco se ha ido teniendo
mayor información del resto del país
recordemos que el internet está cortado
por las mañanas Generalmente hay más
espacio pero durante la noche lo cortan
y de todas maneras en muchas provincias
del país todavía no está funcionando a
esta hora se están terminando marchas
también a favor del régimen en muchas
ciudades del país pero como usted
hablaba hay una anuncio un temor de que
la represión va a hacerse mayor cuando
se cumple una semana de la muerte de
maxada Mini no solamente el ejército
dijo que iba a responder a esas edición
o a esos disturbios sino que los
guardianes revolucionarios también les
dijeron que ellos estaban listos a
apoyar al ejército Para volver a traer
la calma al país y el sistema judicial
también se pronunció y dijo que estaban
listos a llevar a la justicia a todos
aquellos que crearan el caos el caos en
el país Así que lo que nos vamos a
esperar las próximas horas es una mayor
represión una mayor número de agentes de
seguridad en las calles que ya es grande
de por 100 la última semana Así que ya
estamos viendo detención de periodistas
de activistas mensajes a comunicadores
de que no deben salir a la calle y lo
que nos vamos a esperar posiblemente es
es gran represión y grandes detenciones
en los próximas horas y días